okay but i become leader i've never
heard about this right because the fbi
comes and just provides it to a select
few people on intel
so i asked for a briefing speaker
speaker pelosi comes and has this
briefing with me
what i know with what the fbi told me he
should never be on intel
and pelosi reappointed intel
i don't understand this did you have you
said this to her
yes but this is worse i brought a motion
to the floor
to remove him from intel put another
democrat on
the democrats all defended they don't
even have the briefing from the fbi but
they defended him having gone
and think about this he cannot get a
security clearance in the private sector
but they voted to let him have the
security clearance of american secrets
all right i'm live in studio with
congressman
and house minority leader kevin mccarthy
good to see you sir well good to be here
thanks for letting me in the house you
came all the way down from bakersfield
to socal la how do you feel about being
in scary
los angeles well you know i a little
valet county in lancaster but
um the temperature in bakersfield is
pretty hot it's like 105 today so
i thought it'd be a little cooler here
but it's not that much a little cooler
here when you come down to l.a
and uh look it's hollywood i don't did
you make it to hollywood yet i've made
it hollywood yet
it's pretty messy the homeless situation
the drugs
the crime the stores are all still
closed half of the lockdown stuff
what do you make of what's happening i
guess i'm talking about socal first but
just broadly in california you know the
bad part is
everyone thinks okay southern cal so bad
with homeless it's everywhere it's in
bakersfield it's in
every single community but what i really
was shocked the other day when i
came into southern california you've
almost become grown accustomed to seeing
homeless
under the overpasses right and
everywhere but they have overtaken the
the beaches um wilshire boulevard
but what was shocking to me is living on
the freeway
you know you have the banks they
literally built houses as you're driving
yeah and i mean
i i'm shocked by it i'm thinking why and
how can this continue
so so why is it okay so you're a
congressman it's happening in
bakersfield
why is it happening is this all new some
fault like what what is really going on
you know what
um i came home it's not a federal issue
but the first thing i did was
i brought a symposium together my mayor
and i actually flew up kevin faulconer
out of san diego he was the mayor of san
diego it was the only major city in
california that actually decreased
homelessness
right so we got these court cases out
there where you're not allowed to pick a
homeless person up
unless you have a shelter for them but
this is where the cities go wrong like
la they'll spend five hundred thousand
dollars
on a little place to put a homeless
person in they either
majority have a mental problem or a drug
problem
and if you go back to where prop 47 was
and others
people used to be picked up and put in
local jails i just had my law
enforcement in the other day and we were
talking about this yesterday
and what happens when they were in there
they had programs
they would dry up they would actually
make a decision do they want to get
cleaned do they want to move forward but
now they're not now they're on the
streets
you can't pick them up you've got to
give them notice beforehand and you know
what was interesting of why i brought
faulkner up
he put three big tents up one like
all men one women with children and
veterans
and then he did a wrap around he put
health care he put
charter schools so maybe go to school at
two in the morning if that's what's
needed
and he was able to pick them up
move them give them the health care they
need and others to be able to train
these other cities don't want to lean
into it in our community we got together
and
we would clean up we find other shelters
for them
but it's still rampant throughout it it
is a
challenging problem part legal part what
happened in prop 47
part what's happening now on the
treatment side
and now we're finding people that we're
getting treatment they're not and it's a
number of years
so that drug element has gone beyond
that to
be on mental element as well and um
i think a lot of it does come down to
gavin as well though
not tackling it so let's talk about
gavin you know i'm no fan
of gavin i've been screaming about this
recall you just
mentioned kevin faulkner there's a
couple people running
there's four kevin's running is there
four kevin that's not even a big name
wait are you getting into no but i just
read this today four kevin's four
kevin's all right well
look someone gonna win because i think
it was it was a win to at least get the
recall to happen
but it's not the win i mean is there any
chance something happens here there's a
chance we win but
this is what we should all think about
across this country remember what was
happening before the recall
that these governors were becoming so
empowered
that they could tell us whatever we they
could tell us whether we could go to
church they could tell us where we could
eat i remember calling
gavin's chief of staff where he had just
put out
the restaurants could open based upon
square footage who could be in there
but a church could never go more than a
hundred so i talked to him well how did
you determine the restaurant well by
square footage well how do you determine
the church
well not by square footage where's the
science but the only reason he started
lifting anything
is because of the recall so what
happened was
democracy at work it's the first time he
started waking up right
tell us we couldn't do anything but he's
at uh the french laundry right
all sitting together you ever been to
french laundry no i can't afford it
you know they spent 20 grand on the bar
bill 20 grand on the bar bill
is that legal and he was with he was
with a bunch of lobbyists he's with the
the medical association yeah it's a
birthday party it's a birthday party so
what what does california need to really
turn around
whether it's the recall or pushing gavin
to do some things as the recall sort of
we need simple leadership and the
challenge with gavin is
but most people that get into public
service have a philosophy and a
principle and i admire that even if the
person has a different principle
philosophy than i do
because you know where you could find
common ground right no but
our government's not designed that one
person gets 100 of what they want so
how do i keep my principles how do i
find common ground and how do you move
something forward
gavin will change his opinion in a day
and he does it by a poll
where do i need to move here where do i
need to go there those are the people
who fail in this process
and what i'm finding in this he needs
here he is
a democrat governor of the fifth largest
economy in the world
with democrat majorities on both sides
and he's afraid to lead
right well you lose all power when
you're not when you're not leading
and think about what the democrats when
they're looking for the presidential
future
who's their who's the leader of the
party gavin newson and cuomo
and what they did in the what they did
during covent and we got desantis and
christie gnome
they literally used their principles not
letting the federal government tell them
what to do
i think the recall can pass and i think
it would be eye-opening for whoever
could win the race
and remember now that it's qualified
what's the first thing the democrats did
change the law yeah change change
they moved it up also right yeah because
i think it's an advantage because
now that biden is is in and gave him
billions of dollars gavin's going to buy
his way out of it
or try to at least right so if you're
low income and you have a moving
violation you'll pay for it
right here they are with everything
heard about kovan they got 75 billion
surplus i mean it's crazy and then he
held money back from certain counties
but anyways
the last recall was about gray davis
and what happened in that process people
at the very beginning they would pull
and say
i don't want to recall the governor
until they found out who would replace
him
so i really think what california is
looking at to get to the recall
it wasn't a bunch of republicans who
signed it it was independents it was
democrats
and there was a lot down here why
they're concerned about
homelessness but really affordability
they want to go to work
i went to a bunch of the rallies these
were not republicans these were not
conservatives these were people
these were restaurant owners who just
wanted to go to work that's really what
it was
they wanted to be able to live their
life i mean who can't forget that one
young woman
who has that restaurant bar yeah she was
being shut down but the hollywood one
gets to be open
they're with her yeah so if you lay the
rules out and you abide by the rules
you should be able to carry forward but
that doesn't play in the democrat
california they want to change the rules
all the time
so what i truly believe if people are
engaged
we'll win this recall what has to happen
when you go to the vote
you get two questions one do you support
the recall yes or no
and then you vote for who to replace you
need one person to rise up
to be the leader and it doesn't have to
be partisan
i firmly believe that will transfer
and make sure the recall passes so who's
that person
well i don't know who that person is
just yet but now we know the date
we know the date that's something what's
it like for you as
a republican congressman in this crazy
state
just just going around as a conservative
in blue california you know what's
interesting
if i'm on a plane and i'm flying to
florida there's people on my autograph
in texas they'll cheer me yeah yeah in
california new york they'll yell at me
right
but that's okay that's okay what's
happening
is is something i haven't seen in quite
some time
look in california we've had republicans
and democrats
who have managed this state and i firmly
believe
if we could change the top two system
i know why people want to put in the top
two system i never supported it
but the top two system takes us away
from having a debate about ideas
so what's happening in the top two
system we're not getting the very best
people to run
because think about this one of the most
popular governors
in the country is a guy named baker in
massachusetts he's a republican
do you know there's not one republican
congressman from massachusetts
it's overwhelmingly democrat but they
re-elect this
governor maryland right but what's
happening in california you're
not getting the quality people to run
because the top two people think there's
not enough republicans
but if we let the parties decide on at
least all the constitutional offices
we'd have a debate of ideas and what i
truly believe in california people want
to check
and balance that the legislature is so
far
it's not democratic it's socialist right
this wing has gone so far
that they would want to check and
balance that if they got out of control
they have somebody in governor who would
veto the bill i think a republican could
win governor each and every time in
california i think an attorney general
republican could win target closes their
stores in san francisco
neiman marcus they just run it and why
these are the democratic policies that
have now been implemented because they
won the majorities
now we're seeing the outcome that is why
the pendulum will swing
why do you think democrats can't seem to
associate
the people that they vote for in the
policies they vote for for the bad stuff
that happens
like all the people in san francisco
right now that are watching the neiman
marcus video that
we played it on the show and just people
running into walmart and into
walgreens i think 17 walgreens closed in
the san francisco area
just stealing stuff and then you've got
the d.a that won't prosecute and then
now we've got the former
san francisco d.a is now in los angeles
i mean you get it's the swah it's a mini
swamp that we've got here in california
but for some reason people can't seem to
realize oh if you keep voting in the
same party
and things keep going wrong that there's
maybe a connection there to the people
you're voting in
is it the sun it's this it's the weather
right it's friday
you know what i think i think it's a
combination
i don't think these are the democrats of
old if you study history
oh i know i wrote the book yeah
there weren't there were democrats who
weren't crazy there were democrats who
were conservative right
if you took jerry brown's father if you
compare jerry brown who
i think is liberal compared to gavin he
didn't he seemed more conservative
but what what i found now is they have
they have shifted they have become a
socialist
marxist idea and that wing of the party
has become more
powerful and the moderate ring of the
party is afraid
and they can't win anymore are you
surprised how quickly they folded that's
one of the things i'm just focused on
all the time that they
i don't think in his heart of hearts
that chuck schumer is a true
like radical leftist or even nancy posey
i don't really think that he's afraid of
him
yeah maybe she is yeah okay okay but but
pelosi actually gets
that i say that with no love for her
that was like trying to give like a
little bit of credit that i don't think
she's like
over the top aoc but you know what
they're afraid she no she's jealous of
aoc
she believes she was the founding
liberal she's from san francisco
she's the founder and they think of this
aoc has more followers than pelosi
when aoc got elected to congress
remember
she won and i got the number wrong she
she only won and only had to have like
no it's a tiny amount of money
yeah but here she is and she has a name
brandon she she had more followers in
pelosi
she was giving pelosi problems so what
did the speaker of the house do
had a meeting with her and then took a
picture yeah
you know who put the picture out not aoc
pelosi
because she believes aoc is stronger and
then look at this
in the last election pelosi saying she's
going to win
15 seats she got the number right the
party wrong
it's the first time since 94 not no
republican lost
and we beat 15 democrats but the
interesting part is
there is only one wing of the democratic
party that grew
police has a five-seat majority the
smallest has been in 100 years
but the corey bush the aoc the televis
the omars
that wing the social swing of the party
grew stronger
they won and pelosi lost so how do you
take the house back
well we take the house back exactly what
we did in the last election
okay and you've got to analyze it
in the last election had we not had
coveted trump would have won reelection
okay any historical factor you go
through
pandemics the leaders normally have a
challenge
the senate we really thought republicans
would win and think about that
you only needed one seat to win in
georgia and you lost
yeah people could call malpractice on
that right
because think about it if you you're
trying to get me booted from youtube no
no
but if you run as a republican in
georgia
you start with a four-pointed advantage
yeah okay
in the house everyone believed we'd lose
15 seats
even our own even our own pollsters
thought we'd lose but think about this
we win in 2010 we beat 63 democrats
not every incumbent wins so in this last
election with all the wind against us
every single incumbent wins but we beat
15 democrats
every democrat lost to a republican
woman a republican minority
we elected more republican women than
any time in the history
of the party okay so now
only two times in the history of the
country has the party in power meaning
whoever controlled the white house
lose the white house and gained seats in
the house 1892 and 1992 and both times
they won the majority two years later
okay 31
731 votes that's how
short we came up from winning the
majority out of more than 152 million
so what what really happened there was
about four or five seats i didn't have
enough money we didn't to play in
and we lost by less than two points
people didn't quite see what was
happening at the silent majority that's
why when you talk about
can we win the recall in california yes
i don't care what the pollsters say
because momentum the next election is
going to be big
right because all these things about
defunding the police
they're all go all these democrat
policies that are now going in place
we're seeing
the outcome the woke-ism the open border
the
inflation um where we're going to have
the biggest victory
school boards we haven't been paying
attention for the last 20 years
critical race theory goes against
everything martin luther king has ever
told us
don't judge us by the color of our skin
and now they're embracing it
right they're going backwards and the
interesting part here is
okay something else is happening
not just an election and it'll be a
national election for congress
what history says is the party in power
whoever wins the white house
on the first off year election loses 27
seats we lost 40
obama lost 63. so that's and they have a
five seat advantage
in the last election cycle we we
targeted about 50 democrats only one
retired
okay this cycle already five democrats
have retired and i'll bet you that gets
over 10.
and why they're retiring is because you
have redistricting as well
right redistricting doesn't affect the
senate but it does the house
almost every seat unless you go
statewide and what redistricting tells
us
is people move right so we we've got
this amazing
ability the states and the 10th
amendment right
they're like pilot projects they're like
startups right
i mean welfare reform didn't start in
washington dc it started wisconsin some
of our best ideas
are driven from the bottom up not from
the top down and the democrats love the
top down
okay so for the first time in the
history of the state
california's not gaining a seat we're
losing us new york
illinois who gains florida texas
right so what's going to happen here
people are moving based upon the
philosophy
i believe it's going to be an
interesting time because
here the democrats are going to be
sitting back they realize they're in
trouble
they've been in office for a little
while do they want to go have to meet
new constituents and
explain to them why they defend the
message of maxine waters
or why they aren't standing up to
protect our borders or what are they
doing economically but creating
inflation
why are they paying people more money to
stay home instead of go back to work
why are they making our military woke
i think that silent majority is going to
wake up and i think there's going to be
a pretty big swing
so the number one thing you have to have
is the quality of the candidate so what
what does
the the sort of next wave of republicans
look like to you i mean there is sort of
this battle now is it going to be like
the trump wing or is it going to be
the more old school republican wing is
there some brand of that where does
trump fit into this
all right look this way look at it's
interesting within
trump right because trump did a couple
different things um
he expanded the party okay so
when people sit back and think oh i bet
trump really hurt you in the campaign
no he didn't hurt us do you know what
the best state for republicans were
in the last election statewide
well if you're going to tell me it's
california my head's going to explode
because somehow
because what just in terms of four seats
yeah but put it in perspective
trump lost california by five votes
right he didn't compete here
the four seats of the democrats we beat
trump lost all four
three of them by double digits so they
go into the polls
by more than 10 voting points they vote
for biden but by the 10 points they
reject the incumbent
is that shocking to you i mean that's
got to be close to unprecedented that
sort of disconnect between the top of
the ticket
it's the quality of the candidate did
you realize we won two seats in miami
and this is a part you should really
look at do you realize that the
biggest border district in the country
goes from el paso to san antonio a guy
by the name of tony gonzalez
never been elected before trump endorses
him he wins the primary by seven votes
but he wins
it's a 70 hispanic seat
he wins the seat it wasn't even on
people's radars because they didn't
think we had a chance
by a bigger margin than will hurd had
one okay
in miami maria salazar
carlos amines these are democrat seats
but you know why we won
because the population in those
districts are made up of cubans and
venezuelans
who understand freedom they get it they
get it they don't just get it they
left what they see happening on the
democratic side
so we grew in areas people haven't
thought before
now the question was about what's the
future look like
if you look at trump's policies the
majority of americans would agree with
them
personality is what got people at times
to disagree with trump
so if you separate personality from the
policies
and here we are going into an election
where
contrasts make elections happen right so
here we have
policies that we know we had low
unemployment
everybody had a job we looked strong
around the world we were energy
independent
we had a secure border within six months
what have you done
yeah i believe when that debate
is going to be about policy we're going
to win big all right so let's
let's shift from the everyday
machinations of politics and talk to
talk about the other big stuff that i
know has been on your mind it's on my
mind all the time let's talk about the
big tech stuff
we got some problems with big tech and i
know you're trying that's the thing that
can stop us from winning yeah so
so let's talk about that i mean well
first off i guess
how manipulated do you think we are
first like just
generally by big tech like just the way
that we're
able to talk to each other and
communicate more than we ever imagined
more than we even think about okay
you and i should have a discussion let's
discuss your book
don't burn this book and when this
interview's over i'm going to turn on my
phone
i bet you i get an advertisement for it
i'm okay with that
that one i'm okay with but do we think
siri only listens to us when we
talk to him but what's what's even more
important
it's almost every aspect of our lives
right but it's gathering what
information we can know and what we can
think and what we can see
but it's also driving us to dislike
people even if they think
differently than we do and you know
they'll tell you no no
no it's an algorithm who writes the
algorithm you know in 2018
right before the election if you googled
the california republican party
you know what they'd tell you our
ideology was nazism
how was that even in play google and
are you saying it doesn't say it anymore
i'd be happy i'd be shocked if they gave
they came right well they probably
brought it back up today but yeah yeah
but what's happening here from the
aspect of
90 of everybody that searches goes on
google yeah
if you're on the second page 90 drop off
so they control whether you make it or
break it right but they also
if we are a young company moving up they
are
so big they take your technology
they buy you or they crush you right so
you don't have that free market system
you know when you sit back and think who
should have been amazon
sears and roebuck right they have the
catalogs they sold you from a house to
the pair of jeans
to tools they had the resource but
amazon came in a time where there was a
free market they started selling books
they started that
but now amazon's just on amazon amazon
hosts everybody
so if they want to take you off you now
can't be there
if apple doesn't want to put you into
the app
who finds you they control so much of
our live
think about if i grabbed your phone
you'd fight me
if you take your kid's phone away it's
the worst thing that could happen to
them
it's it's almost a drug to us now but it
controls so much
what we can see what we can know what we
can hear and if they disagree with you
they can take you off
if they don't like your competition they
can take you away
that's the problem so what do you see as
the answer is this we go in and we have
regulators look at the algorithm this is
you know i always have this running joke
that you're going to have some middle
management bureaucrat going to google
like let me see the algorithm
as if or are we breaking them up i mean
where does competition fit in like
what's the
this is the way i pray the first
approach we should take is
everybody should realize if something's
on the internet that's free
you're the product yeah okay so if
you're the product we should think of
ourselves as private property right
so if i'm the product and or private
property
what goes on your site if you're
monetizing it i get a piece of it
and i get to know what you're doing with
my information right it's not like this
form
that attorney has to read everyone just
clicks yes or no
let's set a foundation of what the
priorities of these forms should be so
they're clear spoken that people know
what they're getting i get
i get if you're monetizing i get a piece
of it if i want to get off your site
i get my data back if i want to move my
data i can move my data
i think that's a fairness that everybody
starts with the other thing that has to
happen here is though
we've got to make sure there's a level
playing field where there's competition
and i don't think big government
creating utility is there competition
for pg e
no they just raise our rates and they
give us brownouts
and we pay 40 higher anybody else i want
somebody to come in and disrupt
i want the next one right we had
microsoft before we had google
and the other challenge is if somebody
wants to go to courts it takes too long
right so i understand at the beginning
why we gave you section 230
right you wanted the platform to begin
will keep 230 and only this perspective
if you let people say on the platform
whatever they want because it's
liability protection
for you to allow the people to do that
but is it too late i mean i've had this
conversation with other congress people
and plenty of pundits and everything
else like it's like well why didn't
anything happen then
when when they dragged zuckerberg in
front of congress
section 230 still there so if you remove
section 230
now now the platform has a question to
me
if i want to regulate what's on there
right a person has a right to go to
court
if we go to court one time do a big
class action i'll guarantee you they'll
change their behavior
structure dictates behavior right now
this isn't that what trump is now
announcing he's doing just in the last
couple days so he's going to do it
for one moment regardless of how anyone
feels about trump
yeah he had the most
people on facebook probably the most
followers on twitter
he was the president of the united
states our very first amendment is
freedom of speech
and they took them off and the place i
heard the most complaints from
was merkel in germany i mean
think about it 32 years ago a million
college kids went to tiananmen square
for the idea of freedom of speech the
three million people out of eight
million in hong kong that would go out
in the rain
craved freedom of speech and we had just
allowed that to be denied
to an american and then once they did it
to him they did it to everybody else
that they disagreed with why have we
come so far that
you and i can't could sit down you could
have a total different philosophy
we could debate but we don't have to
dislike each other
when we take away the debate we're
taking away a foundation of who we are
i mean i should not be afraid that
someone has a different belief and i and
debate the idea
it either makes my ideas stronger makes
me believe more i mean
i'm a republican but my family are all
democrats i chose to be in this party so
when someone wants to challenge me on my
conservative beliefs
i wasn't born here i chose to come here
i think i'm going to have a stronger
belief
i rejected what somebody said at home
and was seeking out something else wait
let's stick with that for a moment
because i think you know a little bit
about my story
i was i was a big lefty so i'm curious i
didn't know that about you so you come
from a family of democrats
what i was first republican my family
what was your moment
so i'm older we'll get back i'm 56. yeah
reagan was the first president i could
vote for it was it was in the second
term
but when i was in elementary school i
watched junior high
jimmy carter go on tv
put a sweater on tell me to turn the
heater down and told me the best days
of america were behind us he accept
mediocracy
and watch this other guy go to a podium
and says no pastels
fly the bold colors and go to that shiny
city on the hill
i knew what he meant right that
america is exceptional right if you ever
if you come to my office i want you to
come to d.c sometimes
so i have this portrait of reagan behind
me it's in color right
and i have this other portrait that's
very big and it's
lincoln and it's in black and white the
greatest challenge
ever to our constitution was the civil
war
and at night if you sat back and what's
happening and you asked these two people
to give us advice today lincoln would
say
believe in exceptionalism of america and
this is what makes me mad coming off the
4th of july
why wouldn't we celebrate the progress
we're not perfect but as we strive for
our perfect union lincoln said conceived
in liberty
and dedicated the proposition that we're
all equal he goes on to say but if we
fail government of the people by the
people for the people
shall not perish from earth we weren't
the world power but he understood
the strength of what a democracy and
republican were right
there is no other nation in the world
conceived in liberty
and dedicated are all equal maybe israel
but no other one right
lincoln would also tell us this right as
an elected official
don't be afraid of making a tough
decision right the whole debate of
slavery didn't start in 1850
it was the creation of our country but
they thought it was too
too divided too divisional right that it
would divide us
divide the colonies so they said to put
it aside in doing so
hundreds of thousands of their children
died we don't have a decision like that
today
but our debt our challenge with china
right
are we too afraid as elected official to
make a decision that we can lose upon
but what happens is you narrow it you're
eventually going to make decisions but
you have fewer options
and the other thing lincoln would tell
us today is
don't blame other people for your
problems think about he gets elected
november 1860 but not sworn until march
1861.
never once did he blame buchanan he
understood where he was
what was it seven states left the union
in that short amount of time
now reagan i have him in color and this
was a
this is something for you it's for
something for every conservative this is
what he
and he'd even say it to liberals right
if you believe in your philosophy
if you truly believe your philosophy and
principles bring people more freedom
don't be angry be happy i get upset that
these people
say i'm more conservative because i'm
angry all that means is
less people want to have dinner with you
reagan brought democrats in right
people want to know what he was drinking
why was he so happy
you know he had the 11th commandment he
he didn't tear another republican down
he brought humor to it but he knew he
was basically in the rat pack i mean the
guy was cool i just watched a rat pack
documentary he's like he's hanging out
with sinatra like
yeah you want to be around yeah the
other thing reagan would tell us and
this would be critical for the time and
nature of who we are
peace without freedom is meaningless
think about that peace without freedom
is meaningless
it is human nature that we crave peace
but we cannot attain it
without having freedom okay so so many
times in history we watched have people
has failed right
chamberlain peace for our time what'd he
do he claimed he created peace
by appeasing hitler by giving him a
country all hitler understood your
weakness and i'm going to beat you
right barack obama
concerned about iran he gave them
billions of dollars thinking they would
and then said you can
have a nuclear weapon you just have to
wait 10 years there was no freedom in
that so there was no peace
so they took that money and they funded
terrorism around
the gulf reagan had the same dilemma
he's in a second term
he's sitting next to gorbachev he's in
iceland right he's actually having no
staff in the room and he's negotiating
a nuclear reduction he's getting almost
everything he
asked for but gorbachev asked him for
this gorbachev
asked him to end the sdi program
but remember the time and place when
gorbachev has him it was a joke right
people called it star wars
it is the iron dome today that shoots
missiles down it's what protects us
reagan you know what he does he doesn't
say let me talk to congress
he says no but i'll do something else
i'll share it with you so the world will
be safe
gorbachev declines so reagan has
here's a document that he got a lot of
what he was asking for
but it didn't do anything for those in
the gulags it didn't do anything for
requests
so he realized there was no freedom in
it so there would be no peace
so he got up and he walked away and
there's this famous picture of him like
in a raincoat going out rejected yeah
every media elite media criticized him
right
but had he not not walked away at that
moment the berlin wall would not have
collapsed the soviet union would not
have collapsed
and what's interesting to me in modern
time there have been two
presidents that have gotten the nobel
peace prize jimmy carter and barack
obama
the two presidents who deserved it
really were ronald reagan and donald
trump what he did in the abram accords
were amazing
but i thought we're not allowed to call
them that anymore right isn't that what
the administration says they're the
middle east peace not really thing or
something like that they're trying to
tear them down
yeah you know but this is the challenge
when you think about that what drove me
to this party
and i love you know we had a debate the
other day on the floor
to remove statues right every state gets
to send two statues
so the democrats had a bill to remove
these statutes because these were
confederate
individuals so i go to the floor i voted
for the bill i voted for it last time
i said let me just get this straight you
want to remove
democrat statues that were sent to us by
states that were controlled by democrats
years ago and
sent to congress that had a democrat
majority that accepted him
well i just didn't think the bill went
far enough why didn't they change their
name
do you realize is that where this all
ends that it ends with the democratic
party basically having to commit harry
carey because it was
pretty much them who's the first who's
the first republican president
abraham lincoln that's right yeah
because he left he didn't want to be
well the wigs and the wigs and then they
brought they brought the non-slavery
democrats yeah
and then what happened have you ever
thought from that if you're going to
write another book
we should collaborate on this what would
america look like
had lincoln not been assassinated malice
towards none
would we ever had jim crow laws you know
how jim crow laws came and who
who authored jim crow laws the democrats
yeah how did they do it
because after the civil war the south
was controlled by republicans white
republicans and black republicans
and who they elect black republicans
who's the first
black american elected to congress it's
a portrait in my offices too
joseph rainey where was he elected from
charleston south carolina
if you if you study american history the
civil war started there right
he was a slave he was elected in 1870
do you know when the first black
democrat was elected 60 years later
but what happened there got up to 23
black republicans elected
so we had a race for the presidency that
was close
so the democrats cut a deal with the
republicans that will go with you that
you won
if you do one thing if you remove the
federal troops from the south
so they remove the federal troops from
the south you know what happened
they intimidated now black americans
from voting who happened to be
republicans
and the democrats took over the state
houses in the southern states
and that's where jim crow laws were
created based upon joseph rainey now you
want to know a modern history
who's the only black american to get
elected to the house into the senate
house and senate uh tim scott
is okay do you know where he got elected
to the house charleston south carolina
okay yeah
isn't that something but then they
criticize him remember when he got up
and gave a speech
oh yeah they just why wouldn't you
celebrate regardless of a person's color
sin their success
so what do you do with that so right so
tim scott gives the
the speech after the state of the union
and in effect
um everyone's calling him self-hating
washington post wanted to go after him
yeah
if you know anything about tim scott so
tim scott's mother is a saint right
she's an amazing woman tim scott and his
brother
his mom gets divorced right so they
spent a lot of time with her
grandparents
every day they had to eat breakfast and
his grandfather had the newspaper out
and for years tim scott has thought his
grandfather was reading the newspaper
it wasn't until later in life that he
find out his grandfather could not read
but what his grandfather was doing was
instilling in his grandsons
that you cared about current events you
cared about what was going on
you know tim scott's family
had to become they had every reason to
hate america but they did not
martin luther king had reasons to hate
america but he did not
strive to be that more perfect union so
as we hear people want to talk about
what's negative about us
why don't we highlight what's right
about why don't we strive to be that
more perfect union
why do we tear somebody else down you
can have a different opinion and i
but the great thing about america you
have a right to say it so it seems
fairly obvious to me and i think
probably most of my audience that
most conservatives let's say or
blue dog democrats or basically everyone
non-woke
agrees with what you just said there we
can agree to disagree all right you want
this tax rate i want this tax rate
even on abortion i you know in my book i
make a begrudging pro-choice argument
most of my audience is conservative now
and you know what most people said to me
dave i disagree with you on that but
it's all good
and they usually say you'll come around
to my opinion soon enough
but but they don't hate me for it so the
point is that on the right
there is plurality of opinion but what
do you do
i mean this for you personally but also
but also professionally what you do what
do you do with a group of people aoc is
not here to negotiate with you
obviously ilhan omar is not here to
negotiate with you or negotiate what
america is
so what do you do with that you know
what's sad though too
look i i respect them getting elected to
congress is not easy
and think of congresswoman omar's life
right
born in somalia it's not an easy life
lives in a refugee camp
but what does america do she does what
she does
some of her greatness she opens up her
arms she brings her and her family in
and she becomes a citizen of america
right and the moment she raised her hand
became a citizen
the flag that flies on the moon was her
flag
abraham lincoln was her liberator martin
luther king spoke of her dreams right
she has as much right as you and i but
she has as much responsibility
but what strikes me to be odd
why does she have such negative things
to say about the country
that embraced her that gave her think
about this less than
13 000 people have ever had the
opportunity to be a member of congress
not only did america bring her in she
serves
she decides the future of this country
when you think my god this is the
greatest thing on earth
so what do you do with that i mean as a
member of congress what do you do when
you look across the aisle
and you to me i mean maybe i can say
what you can't quite say
i think they're here to burn it down i i
think the simple answer to what you're
saying is
they don't want the america that you're
talking about in the history
well they don't want the history you're
talking about today if they want to
change the names if they if they want
if they want look it crt the whole thing
i think everyone gets it so then
what do you do with that this is not the
democrat that you were across the island
20 years ago division divides this
nation a house divided cannot stand and
that still stands today
we cannot allow that to happen um
i can respect you but you cannot let
them divide the people
and this is this is what's happening on
college campuses right
i got a question from some interns the
other day what should i do even if you
disagree with that person's what they're
saying you should stand up for them
don't let people be bullied don't let
people try to have to have one thing
but this is what's happening and it's
happened into our schools for quite some
time and now we're waking up
it's now happening when it comes to
media which comes to companies they
intimidate you right you can't give
political
you can't have a political pact because
you you can't give to somebody
um in the process we're going to boycott
you
if you don't boycott the the baseball
game
when you don't even know the facts right
i mean this is what has gotten so far so
wrong that these people
and now that we're trying to make woke
into our military
i mean look we should respect people and
the rule of law
should live the day that's one of the
things that makes us strong right
eventually even o.j gets convicted right
i mean
this is a challenge here that what
they're trying to do that in the nation
and study modern history think about
what happened in venezuela
venezuela was a democratic country it
was the jewel
of latin america oil was at a hundred
dollars
hugo chavez got elected not because he
had a revolution he got elected
in a democracy and then when he got
elected what did he do first
he started saying you know what should
have free school should have free health
care
and it costs a lot of money so you know
what
government is more efficient in his view
we should take over those companies
and you know what the supreme court said
no that that's not legal
you know i should pack the courts when
they didn't let that no one would change
the constitution get rid of the entire
congress and lo and behold now i have a
dictatorship
and why does everybody leave your
country because the outcome
just that the same idea is why you want
to defund the police and what's
minneapolis want to do today they want
to put more money into it but
it's worse than that because now people
don't want to be officers
right they're all retiring and you can't
just bring it back on
yeah and then the outcome of what you
get people people shouldn't have to
serve time so we just let people out
they only got homelessness everywhere so
they're not getting treatment so are we
at sort of an intractable place then i
mean one of the things i've been
thinking about is that maybe we really i
don't want the country to break up
obviously but maybe that we really do
need parallel economy sort of linking
this back to the big tech argument
and and that there will be woke things
and then there will be the rest of us
and we will build our things and they
will build their things and i don't know
where the political piece of that fits
totally listen
government is not designed where
somebody gets 100 of what they want
you've got to find common ground what
sets the part from every other country
you go to france you become a citizen
you're not french we're the only country
that you assimilate and you become one
and that's
some of our greatest strengths right and
you're equal it doesn't matter if you're
a man
woman gay straight whatever you are
you're equal
here that sets us apart from every other
nation because they're not like this
you can't let them divide us it's not it
it
it will harm us in the long run if we're
divided now can we have
difference of opinion and respect one
another yes you can
but the idea of trying to divide people
is going to break us and i've watched
that where there's the intimidation of
make it hap
to try to make that happen and that's
where
leadership comes in remember what
winston churchill said it's about us
right
you can always count on americans to do
what's right after they exhausted every
other option
we always think it's the worst of times
right no
in the 60s they killed
jfk they killed bobby they killed martin
luther king
there were riots all in the streets we
were much more divided then
we know the right thing to do what's
happening is
the division is creating people to
dislike people more
to attack somebody based upon their
beliefs
people come to your houses people
intimidate you from other
that is what we should all stand up
against so is that just because it's
fueled by social media now
right because if you think back to the
60s it was incredibly divided as you
said i mean there were at least three
massive assassinations
unfortunately we don't have that now but
i mean within within two years basically
or three years
i mean three assassinations like that so
is that to link this back to the big
tech part
i mean is that because this is all
fueled by information that's just
traveling
like a combination so you've got big
tech and at the same time
you now where do you go to get your news
you don't get your news you get opinion
i go to twitter
yeah okay but if you go to watch
television tonight
you can watch a station that
philosophically agrees with you
yeah that's going to give you opinion
are they going to tell you the positive
things are they're going to rile you up
then you're going to go to twitter and
people are it's human nature that you
can attack somebody you don't know
you can and you can repeat something
that's not true and you could mobilize
something like that and
that's what other countries do to us
they try to divide us within their
bedroom
what what was the soviet union's idea to
to destroy america with no
shot being fired right do with twitter
bots yeah this is
what technology has done to us but
what's happened is if you look at the
four biggest
technology right if you look at uh
facebook google
youtube instagram well they're not four
they're two
right so they can control what's thought
what's said what's motivated what's
popular how to move something at a given
time
that becomes a problem what do we value
right do you value fame or you value
the ability of success i mean anyone who
has a job
has worth has a sense of worth and what
is big
what's big government done tell you no
no you don't need to work
no no we'll pay you to not do that it
takes a sense of worth away from you
and then someone goes and puts all their
risk into something
i mean i started my first business when
i was 20 years old
right so i actually won the lottery in
california on the second day
it was before lottery i was um i was
flipping cards to pay my way through
college i was going to san diego state
to visit some friends at college right
so i go to the local grocery store to
cash a check
teach how wealthy i am so i'm sitting in
line the lottery started the day before
so i'm buying it well you beat this
literally i thought there's a
like i lived in california i was young
okay so i tell my buddy
i said i'm gonna say if i win i'll give
you a hundred bucks i buy a ticket i
scratch off i win the most you can win
is five thousand dollars put yourself in
my place right
you're 20 years old it's 1985 it's
friday night
you just won five thousand dollars and
you end up 10 minutes from tijuana right
okay
uh-oh so i come back i take my folks to
dinner
my brother orders dessert to make the
price higher again
at the time do they cash it out right
there i took it to the lottery store
and then they sent me a check like a
week or two later five thousand bucks
the full amount right so then i went i
took the
kind of the majority the rest of the
money i have i put it all in one stock
so i want to take i want to take a risk
i made about 30
of my money in six weeks okay so i want
to buy a franchise but no one will sell
me one because i'm 20 years old
so i go and i open this deli i even
built a counter in my dad's garage
and there's three lessons i learned from
my small business i was the first to
work
i was last to leave i was last to be
paid
but you know what i'm pretty successful
about a year and a half afterwards i now
have enough capital
that i could pay my whole way through
college as long as i go to cal state
right well
no one in my family finished four-year
degree so i sell my business
going to school open up the paper says
be a summer intern in washington dc with
my local congressman
don't know him but think he'd be lucky
to have me i apply and you know what he
did
you turned me down you wanna know the
end of the story i now sit in the
congressional seat i couldn't get an
internship for
wow only in america could that happen
yeah right
so how can it happen again today if
government will pay you more
instead of go work for the small
business starting out or if you took
all that risk and open it up and they
put you under
is that what this is picking winners and
losers so is that what this really is
all about like this whole conversation
almost everything wrong with the country
because i'm hearing you say that and
it's like man that's what america is
about that's what life is about
purpose and risk and you know all of
those things
and now we have a government i mean
taking it all away
just this morning right before you
walked in i saw this tweet by biden and
it was like we're going to expand
child health care from the state and
we're going to expand to your college
and it's exactly what you're saying
about venezuela like where would you if
you ever wanted to brainwash a
generation wouldn't you just keep
sending them to state schools and say be
more and more reliant on us
i mean to me this is what it's all about
more than more than
big tech part in a way and everything
else just the expansion of
we'll do everything for you you know
what's great is uh richard branson is
going to go to space
privately yeah you know
americans take risk
that's what sets us apart because we
accept risk do we want more attorneys or
more engineers right
an attorney attorney wants to eliminate
risks that have you do nothing
right they want government to do
everything for you everybody
has an opportunity we want to give them
all an opportunity to start but what you
do once you're 18
the outcome is not going to be the same
but the democrats believe everybody's
outcome is going to be the same
no that doesn't work i want you to be
successful as you can but i want you to
have the same ability to be able to be
successful
so be able to take the risk and if i
take the risk and i get reward i don't
want government taking it all
but are you shocked that they've moved
on this equity thing instead of equality
but now that it's it's about the result
not you know the end spot
instead of all of you know what's
shocking so
we don't have what is called a state of
the union in your first term
it is it was a joint joint chambers
um we had and we had the president come
and so you go back and you grow i like
that you you're doing a 10-minute
correction on me there
yeah yeah
you did there it wasn't the state of the
union so it was joint session of
congress but in the first year it's
technically not
yeah it's gonna stay union because they
just came in yet but that was
interesting
you didn't call me out originally then
you slid it in there very impressive all
right
but an entry point so as leader i'm part
of an escort committee so you go back
and you greet the president who's ever
present time
and so this time we're coming out we've
got our mass on right
and then there's bernie sanders and
i disagree with bernie but i respect
bernie he believes what he believes
right
he doesn't back away from him he's not
going to go down in history as passing
any legislation
but he's a movement politician right i
see bernie against the wall i just
talked to president biden i come out i
say to bernie think about this
bernie is the chair of the senate budget
committee
he's a socialist but he's the chair of
cinema but he never backed away he ran
as a socialist right
so i said to him did you ever think
you'd be more conservative than the
president of the united states
he kind of looks at me and kind of
laughs but it's true
all that stuff you just brought up
binding
who's doing it yes biden literally and
i believe most people who become
president try to model themselves after
a former president
biden's trying to model himself after
fdr and think about
all that stuff the challenge of what fdr
did in that place
pack the courts right and this is what
the democrats will do they'll do a
commission because it's not packing the
courts and the commission will come back
watch this will be my prediction the
commission will come back and say you
cannot be a judge after the age of 67 or
something right they'll pick an h
why we'll do that because they'll make
automatically all these people retire so
they can pack the courts
and what he's trying to do he doesn't
love commissions though don't they they
love commissions and hearings that must
drive you nuts
like as like a functional person to be
in government another commission and
another hearing and another
investigation
it's like is anyone doing work around
here you know like actual work
you should be but you know what else has
happened this is what people don't grab
structure dictates behaviors you look at
your congress something has happened
that's never happened before no matter
what challenge we've ever had
in this country you vote by proxy you
don't have to show up
so what does it mean when you vote by
proxy well there are members in the
democratic party that never come back to
congress
but they still vote who has a vote
pelosi has their vote so you're not
going to vote in committee
committee is where you try to work out
you get challenged no no
no i'm just going to bring the bill to
the floor and i'm i've got all the votes
i need so
i don't need to listen to anybody else
that's why you're getting this chaotic
stuff
do they even have to give pelosi an up
or down or she can basically decide i
know they give they give it so they have
to give it to her but but you're saying
because they're not physically there
they're not there they're not debating
they still get paid it's the only place
in america you get paid don't have to
show up to work
yeah it's a great gig my pin tweet for
almost all a lockdown was
if you cut politician salaries until the
country opens up it would be over in two
minutes
right like these people got paid while
they shut us all down through yellow
fever through the civil war through
world war one through over to
we all met it would be important if
do you think the founders would really
think if there was a real challenge
make sure the people the grocery store
go to work make sure the doctors go to
work make sure they're nurses
but you elected officials no you go home
you go protect yourself
no you should lead the nation you should
be at work
no no they don't do it but it empowers
her to be more powerful
i mean that's not good government
i mean didn't we leave the king why are
we creating a new one
what year were you first voted in 2006.
so 2006 so
15 years ago does it see in in the
functional sense not just
sort of optically does it seem that much
worse in terms of being able to do
anything
right now you know i mean not just on
the optic side but like the real ability
if you really
were trying to make something happen sit
down with these guys try to do something
i mean that at the california level and
at the federal level yes
but it's not the worst it's ever been
but is it bad yes
and i do believe that's through
leadership right think about for one
moment
if you sat back and you read in
historical manner and you said
okay joe biden won a presidency but it
was a close election
the senate ended up 50-50 and the house
was the smallest margin that the
democrats had 100 years
oh i bet you had a check and balance i i
bet you've had to find common ground
no you would think it's 2009 again that
the democrats
have 60 votes in the senate and a
40-seat majority in the house
they're just ram-rotting things through
and then they're asking for six trillion
dollars
which any economist will tell you is the
backwards thing to do today
on the money yeah so on the budgets and
all that when they just okay we're going
to tax these guys we're going to spend
this then
like when you get these documents when
they hand it to you they show you the
big you know we all see the big thing of
paper and rand paul goes through it
on festivus when do you get it you get
it five minutes before usually right
but like when when they show you these
numbers like are
in your head are you like what what are
these people talking about you know
you're being like
what are these numbers it's just the i
think the average person at this point
they hear about all this stuff 7
trillion
and everyone's just like it's just made
up it's monopoly money
because it's true i sit in the room
because i'm leader where i have across
the room with pelosi with schumer
secretary of treasury and i want to put
my hair out
there's no basis when you say oh it's
based on science it's based on facts
no no they just pick a number i have to
have this otherwise you can't
do it what what are you talking about i
mean
it it is the most frustrating so how do
you like give me like what a negotiation
is like with that when they when they're
trying to pass something okay they pick
their crazy number
what do you do because you know they're
that you know that their starting number
is
okay let me give you let me give a
recent personal conversation so i go the
oval office
first time seeing the president's been
100 days
president vice president four leaders
president asks can we do a
bipartisan infrastructure bill okay
some other speakers mr president you
asked me let me answer questions so the
first question is
can we do a bipartisan answer is yes we
can well how much money can you spend on
is it
no ms pereira that's the wrong question
if you're asking my opinion
you ask can we would we work with you to
do a bipartisan the answer is yes
now what i would think of how to do that
how do you put the structure together
the first thing is we should both sit
down and agree what is infrastructure
right right that was the thing online
how do you define infrastructure so if
it's roads bridges airports broadband
yeah let's decide what infrastructure is
and then we can see what is the need
then you could decide what's it cost now
we have these trillions of dollars over
here that we appropriated that now you
don't need based upon covid
why spend more money why don't you
utilize those but
if you're asking me what i think
bipartisan would be two
we would need some nepa reform because
some of the biggest challenges you know
you'd say build a road but it's ten
years later before it gets built
even though it's on the same road you're
gonna be so let's reform that so things
happen right away
because look the two greatest threats to
america
are china and the debt
the debt is going to give you fewer
options of what you can do in the future
china spends the time just studying
america either stealing from us
um they have a plan for 2049
one world power you watch what president
xi has said
you watch what they have done with their
military you watch what they've done
with their islands you watch what
they've done with hong kong
you watch what they're saying about
taiwan
and we should be focused and it
shouldn't be a republican plan or
different it should be
one american plan so if the next century
is going to be american century
let's work on it together and
infrastructure would be one of them
but you know what happened even when
people came together and made a
bipartisan plan
the first thing the president we have a
bipartisan plan in the same day said but
i still need six trillion dollars
so why would you ever work in agreement
with them again so who who's driving the
biden thing i mean
do you really think he's in charge i
know you don't want me to ask you this
question but
do you honestly think that this guy's in
charge look when i sat with him
the president is there he's there is he
slower and
not the person that i knew as a vice
president yeah
but i have a real concern
that it's not engaging right
i'll give you an example you can
disagree with trump
within the first three days he had
bipartisan bicameral
all sitting at the table he wouldn't i
watched the engagement all the time
and it's not just who the president is
the people around have to be willing to
engage
speaker pelosi normally always wants to
build just to be
one party those are usually the worst
outcomes you could have you you got to
find common ground
and both people are going to have to
give so it should go through a committee
you create a structure to make that
happen and it'll work
right now the democrats pretty much want
to have it a one-way street
and it's the progressives that are
driving that they would have to say to
them
no you're not going to do it i'm going
to make this agreement and look
if you're president i said you just got
elected you've got this power but if
you're not going to use it you're going
to lose it
what are you willing to fight for what
are you willing to put your risk on the
line for
what are you willing to go out and say
what are you willing to
tell the american public both sides are
wrong this is where we need to go
because
i think in this country we might be
divided but we want to be united
but he's pretty much given them what
they want right oh
totally i mean have you seen him further
to the left no he's further to the left
than
than well that's your bernie point yeah
but you know what
we shouldn't be shocked by that because
remember what barack obama said during
the campaign there is no difference
between joe biden
and bernie sanders but this is a thing
we should be afraid about
he also said that he'd like to have a
third term where somebody else is
president you might have that right now
what do you think he's got a lot of
people in there
he's got a it's got a lot of influence
um
how people handle crisis tells you a lot
right oh it's perfect everybody stumbles
you most of if you write an
autobiography the times you failed will
be the most interesting
part of the book if you quit when you
fail that's the end of the chapter if
you pick yourself up that's the american
story that's why we buy the book right
so the president creates a crisis at the
border
not because we did anything simply
because
if a historian wrote if joe biden became
president
and literally did nothing and kept the
policies of the past administration
we'd be stronger in america today right
but he made these executive orders
simply because he wanted to go the
opposite of trump
he stopped the wall from being built the
moment he was sworn in
right so you have these gaps you have a
you have a gate in california
because of his executive order that
opened up the mechanism broke and they
can't fix it so they put a truck there
to try stuff i mean it's our cake what
they're doing how did he handle it
he first spent the first month with gin
as press secretary
it's not a crisis it's not a crisis
we're setting new records
we're catching people who are on the
terrorist watch list we have a 300
increase in drugs
that are coming across that are killing
people right the kids in cages aren't
kids in cages no they're not anymore
right because we've got a different
person yeah
um fentanyl right but you literally
caught people from
yemen not on the same day
why are they coming who are they talking
to what do they have planned but it's
not a crisis
you set new records more than 20 years
and then when it
comes a point that the public
understands the crisis what does he do
vice president's in charge so what
happens
if china becomes a crisis poo
i'm gonna go meet with putin i'm gonna
be tough i told putin i won't stand with
him in a press conference i've got to go
one on one
i gotta do my own but i told putin don't
you come after these what 12 or 16
different things but you come after
everything else
then he does what does he do i'm getting
tough i'm going to buy an ice cream and
putin's not going to do this yeah he's
done nothing
anybody who becomes president what's the
first thing your adversaries do
they test they test you yeah that's my
fear
is the is that 12 list he had this list
i mean for people that don't know what
you're talking to there's like 12 or 15
things
that he said putin you can't do these
like i mean that almost sounds like the
dumbest
like that is idiocracy 101 these are the
things we don't want you to do
everything else you're good to go and
actually we know if you do these things
it's probably it's probably okay too
right what do you think putin thinks a
kgb
he looks at him and thinks okay i don't
do those 16
but i'll do these one trillion right i'm
gonna do a whole bunch of other stuff i
kept my word
i mean that's exact remember bush tells
a funny story
how putin thinks of everything in black
and white right
like remember president bush at this dog
barney
and he takes putin to kennebunkport he
never took any of the world leader there
right
and and bush made the statement like i
looked into his heart you know
yeah remember the soviet union collapsed
russia's there right so he's trying to
help him
and um barney's there and sees barney
so later bush goes to one of the summer
homes of putin and they're having a
summit putin says to him you want to
meet my dog
schloss dogs yeah putin whistles now
comes his big hound running
you know what putin says look bigger
stronger faster
than barney he thinks in black and white
so when you told putin don't go these
few little things he looks i could do
everything else
i mean his one goal in life
is to try to put the soviet union back
together again
then you got china and what it what did
they do they want to break the dollar
right
so they make an agreement with with iran
he does biden takes over he does
military operations
then what does joe biden tell putin i'm
going to send warships
to the middle east because you just
built up these thousands of people
across
ukraine then biden backs away with the
warship
well they think that's your judgment
right what did president trump do when
he was tested the first time
drop that crazy bomb yeah but how how do
you tell president xi of china
here's some chocolate cake yeah and
mar-a-lago by the way there's 53 cruise
missiles
heading right now you know
obama puts a puts a red line in syria
but he allows him to cross it 12 times
yeah that's the challenge and the fear
that i have
so all right so let's do a little bit
more on china and then i got one other
thing
so all right so on the china front i
mean you know it's funny because your
your demeanor is is pretty
smiley and friendly and positive
obviously conservative
wait but i thought conservatives were
all scary and mean and only care about
war and money
um but despite but you're saying some
pretty scary stuff actually like it does
seem i think most people think at this
point
that china is ahead of us like something
is wrong here and china's just
watching us destroy ourselves destroy
the dollar the leadership is unclear all
that stuff like
is there a chance that they're not in
charge in 2049 i mean do you really see
some
situation where the world yeah it's not
just a chance i mean come on
all right happy conservative brilliant
okay
every company in china is a communist
contingent
company you have to
president xi is a head of the party but
head of the military
puts himself in the constitution that's
not
that's not an opportunity to really have
the best form of government people crave
freedom right
32 years ago a million people in china
went to tiananmen square
what'd they build the goddess of
democracy what'd it look like
statue of liberty where they put it
directly across from mao
what china do they roll tanks in we all
remember that one guy still in front of
the tank
he watched the video stands in front of
the tank tank goes right he moves right
ten goes left he moves left
the tank stops he jumps on the tank do
you know his name
no nobody knows his name because he's
probably not alive
but had that person been a few years
earlier and he was in the eastern bloc
when the soviet union collapsed it would
have been vac volensa
right those people went to tenement
scare
square because they craved freedom of
speech right the thing you have to
understand
america is more than a country we're an
idea
and that idea is more powerful than
anything else around
look there are points in our history
where other people were stronger when i
was in graduate school
in mba i would do swot analysis strength
weaknesses opportunities and threats
let's start with our strength
who's the largest economy in the world
we are
what's the dominant currency the dollar
who has the greatest military at any
given time in the face of the earth
we do do we draft people no
no they volunteer to risk their own
lives for you and i
right when you go around the horn of
africa
and the pirates come in and take you
hostage who comes to save you
the navy seals right when you have a
challenge
how many countries have aircraft
carriers no other country has more than
two but us
right but they're building they're
trying to kenya's
if you live in another nation and you're
sick where do you want to go for your
health care
america if you live in another country
you live in china and you have wealth
where do you send your children to go to
school america
okay so where are people
breaking the law to get into america
nobody's leaving
nobody's leaving okay so we start with a
great deal amount of strength
but we also have a system that allows
disruptors to come
so we improve constantly
in china they have a small group that
decides
they take you off an app they you get
too big for them they collapse
the greatest death rate of any
billionaire is in china
right because they're like well they go
listen they go missing but this is our
challenge
china has spent their time studying
america in every aspect from
stealing from us from growth of food and
others
but they also watched how we fought war
okay
they watched desert storm they watched
it america can move an aircraft carrier
250 miles away from anybody
and come in and bomb you right so what
they spend their time on
building aircraft carriers now but they
spent their time on building a missile
to sink an aircraft carrier
they watch our men and women the troops
don't fight by just getting on land they
fight by space
so you spend a lot of time in space do
you know
the other day china sent three
astronauts to space
did they go to the international space
station
they went to the chinese space station
they don't play with the rest of the
world
do you know china has landed on the moon
on the back side of the moon
the dark side of the boat it's hard to
land there we haven't landed there
china realizes our aircraft carriers so
what did they do
they built islands what'd they do when
barack obama
obama asked him about him we won't
weaponize him she said that
but what did he do he weaponized him to
push us further away
the only time our aircraft carriers in
recent history
were not in the strait there was during
covent
now can we win
the answer is yes the answer is yes is
there a window an opportunity just like
you started with ken
california can we win here i just
created eight
pillars to china based upon coven if
there's any moment in time to wake up
to study right for the rest of the world
to unite
once china found they had coveted what
they do they stopped flights
not international flights domestic
flights
then they dominated the world health
organization to lie to the rest of the
world
they hoarded ppe
then as it went forward and the rest of
the world had it what did they do
well they controlled so much mechanism
what they built when
when france needed ppe even though they
sent
free to china china says we'll sell you
some yeah but you have to have huawei
with you
they utilized covid to get more gain
within their own technology around
the world when australia said they
wanted to study
where covet came from they went and put
sanctions tried to hurt him economically
they said the first place their nuclear
weapon could hit would be australia they
tried to intimidate what you would do
so what america should do is actually
lead would come from strength
we should declassify the information so
the entire world should know why did 3
million people in the world die
and did they need to die why did 600 000
americans die
why did they why did we have to in the
process of coving
the next thing i would do is end any
gain of function
research and end it from this aspect
don't give a grant to somebody else
because you're going around saying my
government's not giving to china but
i give to you because you give to china
right can you just explain what that is
very quickly
gain a function is what you take from a
mechanism
that this didn't come from oh
somebody ate a bat right they were
trying to mechanize and change it and
they were studying it in the process so
meaning
us human scientists are doing this this
isn't that a bat and a monkey
did it and here we are yeah and
do we put funding into it well
apparently for a long time we said we
didn't but we're finding out now we
probably did
make sure the nih which i love doesn't
provide
grants that go to north korea iran
why do we help fund our enemies okay
then why don't we do this why don't we
start looking at
who we're providing our visas to how
many times we've found
somebody from china's over here on a
visa but actually belongs to their
military how many times do we catch them
on a plane
that they are stealing documents how
many times we find out that they're
funding
the professor at the university didn't
swallow sleep with the chinese spy or
something i mean
yes why okay that's a good question i
want to finish my
for the rest of the world yeah when you
get to congress
republicans and democrats decide what
committees you get but there are a
couple committees that are totally
different they're decided by
groups and they're voted on right intel
committee is different than any other
committee because
members who serve on intel can only
serve for a certain amount of time but
they find out
information all the other members can't
have okay
they're only selected by their leaders i
select all the republicans pelosi select
all their democrats
i am part of what is called the gang of
eight right the leaders
and the leader and the leaders in intel
we're provided information
a lot of other people aren't right to
know what's going on
so i can't talk to you about things i
know but
on the intel committee this is all
public domain we can talk about
what we know publicly a chinese spy
and also remember senator feinstein we
found out later
the driver of more than 10 years was a
chinese spy in silicon valley
they've been in pictures together each
of it this woman a chinese spy creates a
relationship with swalwell within his
and the city council
he runs for congress she helps
she puts interns in his office do you
know how difficult it is to get on the
intel committee
when swabble was put on the intel
committee they were in the minority so
they had
fewer seats he was a sophomore getting
part on the intel committee
every single member asked me for the
intel committee there's very few
openings right
there's people highly qualified they're
just not openings form
it gets put on it's not
then the public says that the fbi came
to warn
right they weren't the leaders they had
a briefing he's kept on the intel
committee
this woman they were warning them that
there was a spy basically right
yeah i wonder how they knew she was the
spy right she wasn't just by and then
you had a mayor and other parts think
about how big your spy mechanism must be
if you have enough money to have a spy
that cares about you when you're in the
city council
our talks about you right now there's
some real planning long term
manchurian kennedy remember suavo ran
for president the only thing he has left
is a bunch of shoelaces or something i
don't know
you spent the most money on that but
anyways now you know this you put them
on you did not know
now you know as a leader okay if suave
was in the private
sector he could not get a security
clearance
because he had a relationship with a spy
but
only in america can he be given the
intel committee
where he knows all the secrets but
there's 200 other democrats who are
qualified to be on that slot
and she keeps appointing i become what
is that wait sorry but is that also
because they know damn well that the
media is never going to call him out on
it instead it's oh trump jr had lunch
with somebody seven years ago can you
believe that
yeah but but that's part of it right
that they can keep doing
we're not well i guess we're allowed to
talk about that on youtube now but
oh yeah you probably this is probably
never going to show well yes i'll never
show
you probably don't worry i got
locals.com and it can all go there
okay but i become leader i've never
heard about this right because the fbi
comes and just provides it to a select
few people on intel
so i asked for a briefing speaker
speaker pelosi comes and has this
briefing with me
what i know with what the fbi told me he
should never be on intel
and pelosi reappointed intel
i don't understand this did you have you
said this to her
yes but this is worse i brought a motion
to the floor
to remove him from intel put another
democrat on
the democrats all defended they don't
even have the briefing from the fbi but
they defended him having gone
and think about this he cannot get a
security clearance
in the private sector but they voted to
let them have the security clearance of
american secrets
okay so when you say that to nancy when
you say nancy we got a problem here
there's a spy etc etc nancy just me and
you in the room right now what does she
say
she handles her own members but you know
what they did too they went and removed
marjorie green
yeah for something marjorie green said
before she was of a member of congress
right as if they don't make nazi
references every two seconds these
questions
yeah all right so let's get to the rest
of those pillars and then
okay so the other thing we should look
at is after 9 11
we changed the sovereign laws that
american
if they got killed they could sue saudi
arabia
right you got court your day in court
why wouldn't we do that
to allow the 600 000 who have died their
family
to sue china to be able to get
accountability
do you know where the next winter
olympics is going to be held it's china
right
2020 why would the world why would the
world no
2024 yeah it's coming up quick why would
is it 22 i know i think it might i think
is it 22 or 24
why would the world reward china
why wouldn't we move the olympics
why and i mean why wouldn't we
hold them accountable why after covet
goes through kills more than three
million people
why does china get stronger and the rest
of the world have to be weaker
why wouldn't we unite why wouldn't this
be the opening
why wouldn't this be the wake-up call
why wouldn't the rest of the country sit
back and say
whoa i see what's going to happen so
when you promised the first time i ever
went to china was in 1995 and there was
a sign
in um tiananmen square it was the number
of days and number of minutes to hong
kong came under control
okay it was like a year away and
um when they when hong kong switched
when the uk
they signed a document for 50 years
what'd they do when covet hit
they took it over the apple the apple
daily there the newspaper for 26 years
now shut down
yeah you get less freedom
tiananmen square more cameras less
freedom
in china if someone steals your purse
you'll find it in a minute
not because they're good good at
detective work it's because they have a
camera on everyone
in china if you're chinese and you want
to buy an airline ticket
if you have enough money there's no
guarantee you get the airline ticket you
know what guarantees whether you can buy
the airline ticket
your score everybody has scored social
credit
yes why is it that google would work
with
china but not work with american
military
why is it that nike considers themselves
a chinese company
why does the nba bend a knee so the
question is
can we win the next century yes but will
we will we have the will
okay when i watched what happened at
coven
it made me start thinking you know what
we all thought
the world put china in the wto world
trade organization
they'll become more democratic no they
haven't but they took every advantage
why do they get special funding as a
developing nation
today i mean it's crazy why do they get
this benefit why would we allow this
they're competing with us everywhere
they just put a military base in africa
they want to find one
in the atlantic this road belt system
they they are like loan sharks where
they take these
countries and they give them billions of
dollars they can't afford they say we'll
build the infrastructure
but they lie to them and they don't
create any jobs because they bring the
chinese to build it then they say didn't
pay it i need to take it over i need to
put the military here to protect my
infrastructure i mean they have a plan
you can read it
so i'm still not sure where your silver
lining is i mean it does it doesn't seem
to me that the silver lining is
structured
structure dictates behavior freedom will
always win
out over communism over dictatorship so
you're going to be the long the long
game here which is just that the idea of
freedom is stronger
this is different than the soviet union
right the soviet union we could
we outspent them we can't outspend china
right but what should we do for the same
reasons we started the three
communicates with china
to to do something about the soviet
union
why aren't we working a better
relationship with india they have a
bigger population they care about
america they love america
they love the idea of freedom modi what
he's doing to build his nation
right why don't we start standing up for
freedom around the world
if we take the american belief and we
say when china tells us
that you're going to make a new top gun
again but you can't have taiwan on the
back
when you have john cena say in mandarin
that he's a sorry because
taiwan's a country that's when you're in
trouble
but look at this okay after covid we
should really start and think
are critical minerals or others right do
we make medicine in america anymore are
we too tied to china the supply chain of
what we developed
and we should think of a supply chain
totally different we should think of
the supply chain in america what is when
we started having problems with
ventilators and other what we do
we went to our warehouses where
government bought these ventilators
they sat there and when you needed them
25 years later they weren't ready
so this is what we should do modernize
right we should go to companies
because the free market works 3m builds
masks right
let's say 3m you build a million mass a
year okay what american government's
going to do is you're going to build 1.1
million we're going to buy a hundred
thousand
you're going to store them you know what
you're going to do next year you're
going to put that
and you're going to sell that hundred
thousand you're going to make a new one
right and we're going to go to all of
our allies and we're going to tell you
can join in this too right
so now you're going to have scale so
we're not going to have to
offshore our business over to china
we're going to make them in america
we're going to find critical minerals
that we're not going to let them dump
so our businesses can't survive so
if they're tied if we want to build an
electric car but they control
the minerals how we're going to do it if
we need to make a new
weapon but they control the minerals we
could get into conflict but in 60 days
are we going to be in trouble because we
can't supply ourselves again
it is a wake-up call for us that we
rethink it's the same point
of maybe that we were before world war
ii and others
that that that we got complacent that we
didn't think
long term we thought the world was
harmony right um
we should use the strength position
we're in today for the idea of freedom
america has never gone to conquer
another country
for the sake of controlling it we've
only got engagement for freedom
right that's different than any other
country around us there's other people
around the world that crave that same
thing
that understand that we're more than a
country that we're an idea
so i think if i can sum that up you're
you're hopeful because the uh
our ideas are right their ideas are
wrong but our struggle
is right but yeah our struggle our
division is hurting us
they're getting a benefit over our
division and we should wake up
i'll tell you another story i have a lot
of story yeah okay
so we went to the 75th anniversary of
d-day
very moving and we did a codel and when
i sat and walked those fields and you
look in france
and you look at those headstones from a
star of david to
to a cross but you look at the age you
look at the names
they must have just got into them and
killed on that day right
and you pause for a moment to think what
could we have done before
to not let that happen right let's let's
learn from our stakes and not get to the
point
of there well the challenge of what we
watch with
um china doing and others why don't we
have one policy about that so i went to
the democrats and i said
let's create a committee or a task force
equal number of republicans equal number
of democrats
it took me eight months you know what
they finally said yes
and then we narrowed it down to how many
people could be on it
and we'd look at every aspect right so
we have a plan uh china has a plan so
why don't we have a plan
how do we make america you know from
education from
economics from everything um
we even brought the washington post
reporter in any interview because we're
gonna have that we're gonna have that
article written soon as we announce it
the day before you know what the
democrats did
they backed away they never gave me a
reason but
part of the reason i believe they
thought because coveted hit they did
give an advantage to trump that we are
doing something
that they put politics before country
now the one thing i will tell you if
if we are successful enough to have the
majority and i i'm i have the privilege
of being speaker i will create that i
moved forward and created a china task
force
and two-thirds of every bill that we
brought out was bipartisan
we need to plan for the next century so
that gets me to the last question which
is is that so you want to be majority
leader i mean i think that's
not the majority leader the speaker
sorry the majority right right the
speaker
speaker right right sorry you want to be
the speaker obviously meaning you want
to have
majority in congress look to be on to be
honest my goal my goal is not to be
speaker
my goal is to make the next century the
american century
to do that i believe republicans need to
take the majority i'm going to do
everything in my power to make that
happen
if i become speaker then that's good but
i don't have to be from that aspect
yeah but to get to where you kind of
think america's got to go
that would be a nice little little plan
for you yeah what's happening in the
streets
defunding of the police look what's
happening economic inflation we haven't
seen these type of problems since the
70s
since the last time the democrats had
major control so
i guess then well i'll ask a bonus last
question which is this interview strikes
me as very
hopeful actually and we're not we're not
getting a lot we're not getting a lot of
no
well i always tell people i'm a world
weary optimist i'm an optimist because i
don't think i could do this it's
probably similar to you i don't think i
could do what i do if i wasn't an
optimist
because i have to believe that we can
make things better right but i'm also a
realist
so the world's tough let me let me sum
up that question
yeah bring us home with why you need to
come to my office
yes in my conference room i have the
last painting
it's washington crossing the delaware
it's eight feet by sixteen feet
you know you know that yeah yeah you
know when that took place chris
christmas 1776 right you know when it
was painted
1850 1851 it wasn't painted
wow 75 years later it wasn't painted by
somebody who's there there's no iphone
to take a picture
and he wasn't even an american he was a
german immigrant
who lived in america you know why he
painted it
because he went back to germany and he
wanted germany to have a revolution
based upon the ideas of america now his
talent was art
so he paints this painting and gets it
historically incorrect okay
if you look if you look at the delaware
it looks like the rhine but he's germany
right
he puts washington in a row boat with 13
people
13 colonies right but washington
historians will tell you crossed in a
durham boat
he has washington standing up in the
middle of winter
in a ceremonial uniform with his hand on
his chest you look at why she think my
god
i bet that man has never lost the battle
but history tells us that that moment he
had never won
he'd only lost okay because that was our
first victory when we surprised the
hessians
now when you look at this painting don't
look at washington look at who's in the
boat
the second person he's wearing a bray
he's scottish the person directly across
from in the green jacket rowing in a
cadence with him
is black you come down in the middle of
the boat the person looks like the
strongest rowing the hardest and the red
is a woman
and in the very back is a native
american
now the second to last person is a
farmer and if you look at the farmer
there's a hand across his face it's the
hand of the 13th person nobody sees
you see what emanuel was saying this
young artist
here we are not a country but an idea
having lost
every battle but willing to risk
everything
for the idea of freedom on what most
people would say is our holiest of night
here's a hand when you get it and join
us that's as true today as it was
then the water may still be rough
what we have in front of us may be
different challenges
than we've seen before but if we're all
on the boat together
rowing together from every walk of life
we will win because we are
an exceptional country here's a hand
let's join together
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell